Speaker 1: Going now from don jr to eric trump.
Eric trump pulled one of these tears in my eyes
type stories. He went on fox and friends
yesterday morning and he says when news
of the indictment broke, he was on a plane
and that everyone in the plane came up to
him to hug him. And as always, it's like,
do we believe these stories, guys? Justice?
Speaker 3: And and guys, I have to tell you,
people in this country understand it. I was
on a plane I was on a commercial flight when this
whole indictment broke. People were coming up to
me giving me hugs. The support is unbelievable
out there because people understand that we've
literally become a banana republic.
Speaker 1: We're now literally a
banana republic. Maybe he means.
Speaker 3: Figuratively. They've made
a mockery out of our legal system in this country.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So I'm sure that that happened.
And, you know, a lot of them were really big,
strong guys. Some of them were crying and they
said to the flight attendant, bring this man
more peanuts because of how unfairly his family
has been treated. And the next thing you know,
the pilot came out of the cockpit, saluted Eric
Trump, and they all did the Pledge of Allegiance.
And it was just an incredible, incredible day. I
don't believe any of it, obviously. Then during
the same appearance, he tries to say something
about free speech and it goes very, very wrong.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Rachel, We're supposed to
live in a free country. There's freedom of speech,
right? It's just the number one thing that
makes up our Constitution. Freedom of speech,
freedom of expression. You have a service all
over the country who are getting deplatformed.
Their businesses are getting shut down.
Speaker 1: Who's that? Who is he talking about?
Speaker 3: Banks. Stop banking
them. They're their web service
providers. Decide to turn them. Turn them.
Speaker 1: Away. It is true that Web hosts,
when they find out that they're hosting extremist
content, sometimes will say, we're not hosting
this nonsense anymore. That is true. But they
want to pretend as though the indictment of
Trump proving or proving, suggesting that even
presidents aren't above the law is somehow an
attack on everybody. And as a follow up to the
Eric Trump thing from last week, remember how last
week I played this clip for you where he relates
CVS and Kyle Engel, not Tylenol. Kyle all somehow
to this indictment. Remember this clip.
Speaker 3: It is every single day and this
is a city I spent a lot of time in Europe that
is falling apart. I went into literally CBS the
other day, and you can't buy Tylenol because it's
locked behind these glass counters because there's
so much theft and there's so much looting there.
Speaker 1: So, yeah, So he wasn't able to get
Tylenol at CVS. He then went on Newsmax and told
a totally different version of the story where
he says, you actually it's it's Advil, you can't
get it. Duane Reade. Now, people in other parts
of the country may not know Duane Reade. Duane
Reade is like a more local CVS. It's similar and
they sell other things as well. So wait a second.
Are you telling me that you first went to CVS and
they had no Tylenol without a key and then you
went to Duane Reade and you couldn't get Advil?
Or was it just the entire thing was made up.
Speaker 3: In your city? Homelessness is through
the roof. I went to Duane Reade the other day.
Did you? And literally you can't buy Advil and
Duane Reade without having somebody come up
with a key and unlock, you know, those little
plastic things that you pick up? Yeah, because
there's so much looting in the city. I mean,
the city is going to hell right now.
Speaker 1: You look nationally,
just about every every Walgreens, CVS,
Duane Reade, they're all locking up all
of this stuff. As I said last week, my hair
product is regularly locked up now. I mean,
it's in very high demand ever since I started
using it. But my girlfriend's deodorant is
locked up. Something I got for my baby daughter
was locked up. I don't remember what it was.
Might have been like babies or tech was locked
up. This has nothing to do with not prosecuting
or prosecuting Trump. And whether it's Kyle
and all or bile and all or whatever it is. I
don't believe a word this guy says, but he is
not doing well, clearly. And I get it to some
degree to see my dad indicted and then begging for
money, even though he's supposedly a billionaire.
It would probably upset, upset me as well.
And that's what I want to talk about next